un témoignage précieux pour débuter ce
journal celui d'une jeune femme
politique
ukrainienne engagée déterminée à ne rien
céder face à l'agression à eux une femme
actuellement de passage par Paris pour
rencontrer les élus français c'est vous
les sièges à silenco bonjour merci
d'être là de nous faire l'honneur de
vous arrêter ici sur ce plateau de
FRANCE 24 vous êtes ici à Paris pour
rencontrer des élus on va on va reparler
dans quelques instants vous avez déjà
régulièrement témoigné sur notre antenne
depuis Kiev vous avez très vite décidé
de rester malgré l'offensive l'offensive
russe le monde a découvert votre visage
via ce cliché c'était tout au début du
conflit on va vous le montrer à nouveau
celui d'une femme politique mère par
ailleurs de trois enfants et qui
pourtant n'a pas hésité à prendre les
armes et signe kalachnikov posait sur
votre votre bureau c'était au début de
l'offensive russe pour défendre disait
vous votre votre pays vous disiez
déterminer à vous battre pour défendre
l'Ukraine ses valeurs face à l'agression
des Russes
il s'en est passé des choses depuis
cette photo c'était il y a plus de huit
mois maintenant comment allez-vous déjà
c'est une bonne question à vous savez
c'est juste quelques semaines que j'ai
commencé à réfléchir qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire de vivre dans une guerre une
guerre totale qui a
pris tout le pays où j'habite et les
conséquences de cette vie comme ça on
dit en Ukraine qu'on n'a pas à une
balance de
boulot vie mais plutôt dans une balance
de guerre vie donc je sais pas je pense
qu'il y a plutôt une balance vers la
gare que vers la vie vous êtes engagé
politiquement d'où j'imagine aussi son
choix vous êtes également mère de trois
enfants je crois que vous avez
d'ailleurs un moment donné dû faire des
allers-retours vous avez mis vos enfants
à l'abri je crois que vous ne souhaitez
pas communiquer où ils sont vous vous
inquiétez pour votre famille aujourd'hui
malgré tout
bien sûr j'ai mes enfants qui qui sont à
l'étranger je les ai mis à l'étranger le
1er mars après avoir vécu une semaine
dans un environnement de guerre de
sirène et j'ai compris que ça va durer
pour un temps indéfinitif et comme
chaque mère je veux le meilleur pour mes
enfants je veux une enfance pour mes
enfants je veux surtout une enfance avec
une bonne éducation pour mes enfants à
ce moment-là les enfants Ukrainiens qui
restent en Ukraine sont déprimés de tout
ça puisque même l'école en ligne qui
continuait depuis le covid qui continue
pendant la guerre maintenant c'est à
s'est arrêté puisque les Russes sont en
train de bombarder les lignes
électriques les réseaux d'énergie il n'y
a même pas les moyens de faire l'école
en ligne donc c'est pour ça c'était une
démanaison la sécurité aussi maintenir
un niveau de vie normale un niveau
normal pas tout à fait normal malgré
tout puisque vous vivez quand même à
distance vous vous avez décidé de rester
très engagé pour votre pays vous vous
faites partie des rangs de l'opposition
je crois qu'il y a plus vraiment
d'opposition d'ailleurs en ce moment
c'est un combat pour le pays évidemment
et pour pour l'unité vous êtes ici à
Paris parlons-en vous serez reçu cet
après-midi à l'Assemblée nationale vous
avez déjà été reçu hier à l'Elysée vous
avez rencontré ce matin des sénateurs ça
fait un gros carnet de de rendez-vous
parce qu'il faut du concret j'imagine
qu'est-ce que vous réclamez aujourd'hui
aux Français notamment de l'argent de
l'argent mais aussi des armements les
armes les armes c'est toujours la
première chose qu'on demande pendant ces
9 mois de guerre puisque ce sont les
moyens avec lesquels on nous défend on
Ukraine mais avec lesquelles on aussi
défend les les valeurs principales de
toute l'Europe si on veut pas avoir la
guerre en Pologne en Lituanie en
Roumanie on doit défendre l'Ukraine on
doit faire cette contre-offensive contre
le régime autoritaire de Poutine on ne
fait pas suffisamment assez c'est ça que
vous êtes en train de dire je crois que
l'Ukraine a reçu hier de nouveaux
systèmes occidentaux de défense entière
cela même qui était réclamé par volody
merzeninski depuis des semaines cela
même qui sont destinés à contrer des
fameux missiles russes qui qui tombent
sur votre pays tous les jours depuis
depuis le mois de septembre vous savez
chaque fois je dis un grand merci à tous
les nations tous les gouvernements qui
continuent à fournir des des armes à
l'Ukraine mais chaque fois j'ai besoin
aussi de remarquer que ça prend un peu
trop de temps on n'a pas ce temps à
perdre parce que chaque jour de guerre
c'est des pertes c'est des pertes
physiques des pertes de vie pour les
Ukrainiens mais c'est aussi des pertes
économiques de stabilité pour le reste
du monde et ce que je veux dire c'est
que le monde doit se réveiller déjà on
doit comprendre que la Russie a un état
agresseur et que ça va rester un état
agresseur sous Poutine et le seul moyen
de changer cela c'est vraiment de
négocier avec de la force et cette
négociation avec la force ça ça veut
dire qu'on a besoin des armes des armes
pour l'Ukraine mais aussi un changement
de l'industrie de sécurité de la défense
ça doit doubler les efforts ça doit
produire beaucoup plus en beaucoup moins
de temps et il doit avoir des armes ici
en France mais aussi des armes qui
peuvent être envoyées en Ukraine parce
que autant que Poutine reste au pouvoir
autant que la Russie reste sous ce
régime autoritaire ça va être toujours à
une source de danger une source de
risque de sécurité pour non seulement
pour l'Ukraine pour les voisins
immédiats de la Russie mais aussi pour
le monde entier la France y inclut ça
c'est évidemment l'argument et on le
comprend utiliser aussi par Kiev par
volody merzelinski pour tenter de
mobiliser au maximum les occidentaux les
Européens en premier lieu
vous vous êtes aussi menacé j'aimerais
vous interroger sur cet article du
Washington Post l'administration de Joe
Biden tenterait discrètement
d'encourager via des canaux secrets le
président
ukrainien a négocié directement avec
Vladimir Poutine le quotidien américain
parle de pour parler secret alors est-ce
que vous vous imaginez une seconde qu'un
échange comme celui-ci élu en tout cas
que des pourparlé de paix soit engagés
incessamment sous peu à l'administration
de Joe Biden c'est très bien les
conditions pour ces négociations il y a
les conditions c'est c'est pas hors de
la table d'avoir des négociations mais
pour que ces négociations puissent nous
fournir avec des résultats concrets et
des résultats long terme on a besoin que
l'Ukraine soit déoccupé que tous les
territoires
Ukrainiens la Crimée inclus soit
déoccupée et que les frontières
craignent retournent au niveau de 1991
quand l'Ukraine a été proclamé à un état
libre et un État indépendant donc ça
c'est la base de cela on doit commencer
si négociations on peut pas négocier on
peut pas signer des contrats des à
commencer malgré tout à échanger et à se
dire on va essayer de calmer le jeu
j'entends votre argument mais vous
parlez des frontières de 91 alors là on
y est pas du tout du tout c'est aussi
prendre le risque que cette guerre elle
ne s'accélère vous parliez du risque
pour les pays voisins la Pologne la
Roumanie ou parler du risque également
pour pour l'Europe tout entière est-ce
qu'à un moment donné il va pas falloir
qu'une des parties des sites de calmer
le jeu vous savez on l'a déjà fait
2016 quand il y avait les négociations
autour
de la Crimée autour des autres
territoires occupés de l'Ukraine est-ce
que ça fait vous connaissez très bien le
résultat le 24 février cette année là il
y avait une invasion totale de l'Ukraine
tout ce que les Russes pourrait utiliser
comme Gary long utilisé le blé la
nourriture l'énergie le nucléaire ils
ont frappé des objets civils il continue
à le faire jusqu'à aujourd'hui il ne
s'arrête à rien
est-ce que la menace nucléaire vous y
croyez semblerait que les Américains ont
souhaitent assez inquiets doux c'est
pour parler secret et d'où cette
nécessité selon Washington Post de
maintenir les canaux en tout cas de
communication ouvert la communication
est toujours ouvert mais les Russes
savent très bien les la base pour cette
négociation et ce qu'ils doivent faire
sans cela ce serait de négociations
sous
sous arme sous force et
de négociations sous forme ils vont pas
donner des résultats long terme stables
donc c'est pour cela qu'on doit tout
d'abord de occuper le crâne les
Américains le sachent aussi et quand
elle votre question sur le nucléaire
sous cette menace nucléaire bon il y
avait les garanties que l'Ukraine a
obtenu quand l'Ukraine à dénoncé ses
armements nucléaires et ses garanti
provenaient de tous les autres États
nucléaires des États-Unis de
l'Angleterre du Royaume-Uni de la France
en inclus de la Russie inclus que aucune
aucun pouvoir nucléaire ne
agressera pas à l'Ukraine lac carapace
attaquer les autres pays ce sont des
mots rien ce sont des mots effectivement
une dernière une dernière question
on parlait tout à l'heure avec notre
correspondant à Kiev du terrain la
grande bataille de Carson qu'on nous
annonce depuis des semaines vous disiez
en avance malgré tout il semblerait
effectivement que l'armée ukrainienne
souhaite à l'offensive sur le front sud
sur sur le front est également les
Russes qui sont en train de de reculer
est-ce que vous envisagez vous ces
prochains mois ces prochaines semaines
vous en tant que femme ukrainienne
d'abord en tant que mère aussi de trois
enfants en tant que femme politique ça
fait beaucoup de casquettes mais comment
est-ce que vous envisagez ces prochains
mois et là encore quelques semaines
quand l'armée ukrainienne peut faire des
des contre-offensives des avancements
bien concrets et bien fort et pour cela
c'est pour ça que qu'on a besoin ces
armes et les armes qui doivent arriver
le plus vite possible parce que après
cela quand le froid arrive les deux
armées les
Ukrainiens les Russes ils vont essayer
de
se rétablir dans les positions où ils
sont ils vont avoir quelques mois
d'hiver pour vraiment renforcer leur
position et ça ça va faire la guerre
beaucoup plus difficile il faut que ça
évite si je vous suis bien il faut que
ça aille beaucoup beaucoup plus vite et
pour cela on doit avoir des armes pour
nous défendre pour défendre nos ciel
surtout mais aussi des armes pour
avancer la contre-offensive et pour
libérer les territoires Ukrainiens nous
votre présence à Paris ce sera ma
dernière question est-ce que vous avez
une réponse positive des autorités
françaises vous avez été reçus à
l'Élysée hier est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment en tout cas qui a cette
volonté au moins affichée il y a la
volonté de soutenir l'Ukraine il y a un
clair message que la victoire arrivera
quand les Ukrainiens vont choisir cela
et la victoire pour l'Ukraine c'est la
victoire pour la France
on continue à faire notre travail et moi
j'espère que les Français vont donner le
soutien pour qu'on puisse établir une
Ukraine indépendante et la démocratie
plus qu'un juste un mot mais comme une
vraie valeur dans le continent européen
et on ne peut que le souhaiter merci
beaucoup lessive vacciner quoi merci
d'avoir